They say you should always prepare for the
worst, but it turns out that these beloved
actors didn't have to. From horror
classics to historical epics, these
hit movies featured stars who weren't exactly
optimistic about their work during production.
"Boogie Nights" was seen by many as a comeback
movie for Burt Reynolds. The peak of his fame
was already long behind him, and he had
spent much of the '90s in forgettable,
if not outright embarrassing films. For
the first time in a good number of years,
he was getting praise for his acting,
and he would go on to win a Golden
Globe and be nominated for an Oscar for his
performance as adult filmmaker Jack Horner.
Surely Reynolds appreciated what
"Boogie Nights" did for his career,
right? Not even close. Reynolds famously bashed
the film every chance he got and continued to
express regret for his involvement as recently as
2015 — 18 years after the movie's release and just
three years before his death. The veteran actor
claimed that he didn't even want to do the movie
in the first place, and said that he had turned
it down seven times before finally giving in.
Reynolds also said that he hated working with
writer and director Paul Thomas Anderson — so
much so that he had to be physically
held back from assaulting the filmmaker.
If that wasn't enough, Reynolds just
wasn't impressed with the movie or its
subject matter — and he didn't see
how anyone else possibly could be.
"You wanted to hit the director, Paul Thomas Anderson, you wanted to hit him in the face."
"Uh, no, I don't want to hit him in the face. I just wanted to hit him."
The 2007 movie "300" was arguably the breakout
project for both its director and its lead actor.
Zack Snyder had received acclaim for his "Dawn
of the Dead" remake, but it was with "300" that
he truly established the filmmaking style that
would follow him for much of his career to come.
As for Gerard Butler, Leonidas was far from his
first film role, but it was his first huge hit
as the top-billed player. When looking back at the
film in an interview with The Hollywood Reporter,
Butler revealed that he and Snyder connected
immediately during their first meeting, and
were mutually excited to work together. But once
the actor got on set, it was a different story.
"300" was filmed entirely in front of
bluescreens, with its backgrounds filled
in digitally during post-production — something
much more common now than it was at the time.
It was certainly a new experience for Butler,
and he had a lot of trouble envisioning what
the final product would actually look like as
a result. While watching an actor reacting to
a burning village while simply pointing at
a bluescreen, he couldn't help but think —
"Oh my God. This movie's going to suck."
Once Butler saw the finished film
with the added effects, however,
he was blown away — and thankfully for
both him and Snyder, audiences were too.
"Friday the 13th" bad guy Jason Voorhees
has become an icon of the horror genre,
the hockey mask-covered face of the long-running
franchise. He's appeared in everything from comics
to a Mortal Kombat game, but he wasn't the bad
guy in the first "Friday." Most of the killing in
the 1980 slasher movie was done by Jason's mother
Pamela, who was played by the late Betsy Palmer.
Palmer once admitted that the only reason
she appeared in the film was because she
needed a new car — and she had her eye on a
Volkswagen Scirocco. As soon as she realized
that she would be portraying the villain in a
low-budget horror flick, Palmer assumed that
the happenings at Camp Crystal Lake would come
and go without much fanfare. As she admitted —
"So the script came and I read it and
said, 'What a piece of [s---]. No one
is ever going to see this. It will come. And
it will go. And I will have my Scirocco.'"
Instead, "Friday the 13th" was a smash hit,
turning Pamela Voorhees and
her son into horror icons.
"Don't let her get away,
mommy. Don't let her live!”
“I won't, Jason. I won't."
Tommy Lee Jones is known for playing
no-nonsense characters that aren't
afraid to hurt feelings — and if
his co-stars are to be believed,
Jones himself has a similar reputation. From
his disdain of Jim Carrey on the set of "Batman
Forever" to his clashes with director Barry
Sonnenfeld during the production of "Men in
Black," there might be a good reason why Jones
is frequently typecast as a crotchety grump.
Even while working on the movie that earned
Jones his only Academy Award thus far,
"The Fugitive," Jones still didn't seem all
that happy to be there. He also didn't seem
to think the movie was any good. In a
Rolling Stone oral history of the film,
Jones recalled a moment when he was filming
a scene and things just weren't falling into
place — so he immediately assumed that the
worst was going to happen. As he put it —
"I remember thinking in the back of
my mind, 'I'll never work again. This
is never going to work.' And the best
thing I can do is be as clear, concise,
and coherent as possible, deliver these
lines as cleanly and dutifully as possible,
and maybe I’ll get another job
one day, somewhere down the line."
Like many people in Hollywood, Chris Pratt
was hesitant to believe the first "Guardians
of the Galaxy" movie could succeed. After
all, the Guardians were a C-list squad with
far less name recognition than the Avengers
and X-Men. Both Pratt and director James Gunn
admitted that they were both worried
that their careers would be over if,
as some pundits predicted, the film
turned out to be "Marvel's first bomb."
Pratt in particular was amazed that
Marvel even opted to fund the project,
remarking about Hollywood executives —
"Everyone wants to win big,
but no one wants to gamble."
The actor continued —
"Every rule said, 'You don’t make
a movie with a talking tree,' 'You
don’t spend this much money on
a raccoon with a gun.' For me,
I was like, 'Oh, so this movie is going to
bomb. Done. This is the end of my career.'"
"There's a little pee coming out of me right now."
More than $700 million and heaps of critical
praise later, the Guardians were household names,
Pratt was the face of a franchise, and Gunn was
one of Hollywood's hottest writer-directors.
It may have come out two decades ago, but
"Elf" is still one of the newer films to
be added to the list of undisputed Christmas
classics. Directed by Jon Favreau before his
jump to Marvel and "Star Wars," the movie
stars Will Ferrell as Buddy, a human man
who grew up among Santa's toy-making elves.
After he learns the truth about his existence,
Buddy makes his way to America — and he gets
into some pretty wacky hijinks once he arrives.
Will Ferrell is one of the most famous comedians
around nowadays — but in 2003, he had only
recently left "Saturday Night Live" and was still
beefing up his filmography. He still had a famous
face, though. While filming the outdoor scenes for
"Elf" in New York City, the cameras were hidden so
that Ferrell could get some real reactions out of
real people. Unfortunately, some of those people
recognized him — and as a result, they expressed
concern over the fact that he was walking around
in an elf costume and asked if he was doing okay.
The experience made the actor question whether the
movie was going to work on the big screen, and he
worried that it was going to effectively end his
movie career just as it was beginning. Obviously,
the movie ended up resonating with a lot of
people, and "Elf" was a hit in its day before it
became an enduring classic of the holiday season.
Richard Dreyfuss was fortunate enough to star in
several undeniably classic films fairly early in
his career, as he ended up on the radars of future
icons George Lucas and Steven Spielberg early in
their respective Hollywood journeys. "American
Graffiti" ended up being Dreyfuss's first big
role, and he added both "Jaws" and "Close
Encounters of the Third Kind" to his resume
before the end of the 1970s. With "Jaws," Dreyfuss
got to be part of the movie that is often said to
have invented the very concept of the summer
blockbuster — and everyone involved seemed to
understand that it was something special.
Everyone, it seems, except for Dreyfuss.
In a career retrospective he did for Yahoo,
Dreyfuss said of the vibe on the "Jaws" set —
"Everyone had thought they
had struck gold, and I said,
'What are you talking about? It's just a
little movie.' So when the film was released,
I found myself going back to the talk shows and
saying 'I'm the guy who didn't believe in it.'"
He couldn't have been more wrong.
"Jaws" was so big that it set new
standards for what it means for a movie to be big.
Bill Murray voicing the main
character in 2004's "Garfield:
The Movie" felt like a full-circle moment for
many fans. Garfield's voice from 1982 to 2001
was an actor named Lorenzo Music, and he
also played Peter Venkman in the cartoon
"The Real Ghostbusters." Since Music died
in 2001, he couldn't voice the live-action
Garfield — so who better to step in than
the original live-action Peter Venkman?
Still, nostalgia wasn't the reason Murray signed
on to voice everyone's favorite lasagna-loving fat
cat. When he saw that the movie was co-written
by Joel Cohen, he jumped at the chance to work
with one of the esteemed Coen brothers, who proved
their comedy chops with "Raising Arizona" and "The
Big Lebowski." As Murray was recording his lines,
he was shocked at how bad he thought they were,
but he stuck with it and tried to make the
best of it. When things didn't improve,
he asked to watch back the scenes that had already
been cut together — and he remarked out loud —
"Who the hell cut this thing? Who did
this? What the f--- was Coen thinking?"
That's when someone informed Murray that it
wasn't the Oscar winner Joel Coen; COEN, who
had worked on "Garfield," but Joel Cohen;
COHEN, with an “H”. At that point he was too
deep to back out, so he finished the job
on what ended up being a box office hit.
"So do you have many regrets?"
"Garfield, maybe."
Australian actor Geoffrey Rush knows his way
around an Oscar-caliber performance — he's
delivered four so far, winning for "Shine"
and receiving nominations for "Shakespeare
in Love," "Quills," and "The King's Speech."
That doesn't mean he always knows going into
a project that it's going to be acclaimed, let
alone that anyone is even going to be bothered
to see the movie at all. He had serious doubts
about one of those very projects — and he ended
up eating his words. Despite his prediction,
"The King's Speech" was an undisputed success.
Rush reminisced on the moment he
first received the script for the
historical drama about King George VI's
struggles with stuttering, recalling —
"When we sat and read the initial
script [...] the first thing I read was,
'Well no one will want to go and see this,'
let alone, 'Oh this is an Oscar-worthy film.'"
With that in mind, Rush found it rather
funny when people accused the movie of
being so-called "Oscar bait." But
whether or not that was the case,
it snagged an impressive 12 nominations and
won four, including Best Picture. As for
Rush's assumption that nobody would go to see it
— "The King's Speech" was a surprisingly massive
box office hit for a movie of its kind, netting
over $400 million at the worldwide box office.
It's no big secret that Robert Pattinson
was never entirely comfortable with
the level of fame that starring in
"Twilight" brought him. Thankfully,
he's done more than enough acclaimed work
since then to successfully distance himself
from the five-movie franchise — and nowadays,
he's more commonly associated with films like
"The Batman" and "The Lighthouse." But
why would Pattinson take on the role of
the famously sexy vampire Edward Cullen if he
didn't want to be a globally famous heartthrob?
It turns out that Pattinson didn't
think "Twilight" was going to be
that big at all when he auditioned and
eventually accepted the role. Even though
Stephanie Meyer's urban fantasy saga was an
unavoidable phenomenon in the United States,
it was apparently much less popular in Pattinson's
native London. He claimed that when he tried to
buy the books for research after he was cast in
the first movie, he couldn't find any stores in
the city that even sold them. He also stated
that among his circle of friends and family,
he only knew one person who had read the books
— a friend of his sister's. Given all that,
along with the fact that director Catherine
Hardwicke had only done relatively small films
up to that point, Pattinson had no reason to
expect "Twilight" to make much of an impact.
Even though Jackie Chan was an international
action movie superstar dating back to the 1970s,
he struggled for years to fully
break into Hollywood. It wasn't
until "Rumble in the Bronx" made it to
the States in 1996 that Chan finally
got the crossover hit that had eluded him
for so long. Two years later, he starred
in the American-made buddy cop action comedy
"Rush Hour" alongside comedian Chris Tucker,
and it ended up being the biggest worldwide box
office hit of Chan's career up to that point.
While filming "Rush Hour," though,
Chan didn't think it was working. He
was frustrated about not being given more
creative control over his fight scenes,
and he had concerns about the language
barrier between himself and Tucker.
"Do you understand the words
that are coming out of my mouth?"
Chan had no faith in "Rush Hour" at
all — so much so that, even when the
audience at the premiere was loving it,
Chan told Yahoo that he was thinking —
"Why are they laughing, I just don't understand."
The fact that "Rush Hour" tanked in his
native China only seemed to reinforce
Chan's feelings on the movie's quality
— but it was an undeniably huge hit in
the U.S. Its sequel did even better at
both the U.S. and worldwide box offices,
even though Chan thought it was
even worse than the original.
James Marsden has had an interesting and varied
career, one that includes comedies, dramas,
video game adaptations, musicals, superhero
movies, and more. He's also done his fair share
of romance films, including one that's especially
iconic among fans of the genre — "The Notebook,"
the 2004 Nicolas Sparks adaptation that stars
Ryan Gosling and Rachel McAdams in the lead roles.
Marsden played Lon Hammond, the guy who McAdams's
Allie ends up with after she thinks Gosling's
Noah has stopped writing to her — and she later
cheats on him with Noah when they reconnect. It's
all pretty standard Nicolas Sparks fare, which
is exactly what Marsden worried about while he
was making the movie. In an interview with Out
magazine looking back at his career, he joked —
"There are some movies that I've been in
that I was sure people would laugh at,
that have become huge. I thought 'The
Notebook' was going to be a schmaltzy
Movie of the Week-type thing, and here we are!"
Whether "The Notebook" is schmaltzy or not
is a matter of opinion — but as far as money
is concerned, the raw data speaks for itself. The
movie grossed over $100 million at the box office,
and it remains the best-reviewed
Nicolas Sparks adaptation to date.
It has since been reappraised in a
less positive light by a lot of people,
but "Forrest Gump" was a crowd-pleasing hit
when it came out in 1994. Star Tom Hanks even
saw fit to come out and defend the movie against
its detractors, saying that it's only because
the movie was such a big hit that people have
seen fit to take shots at it in recent years.
It's interesting to hear Hanks going to bat
for "Forrest Gump" now, considering that he had
moments in which he wasn't especially confident in
the movie while the movie was being filmed. During
the 2023 New Yorker Live event, Hanks admitted
that he questioned director Robert Zemeckis on
whether anyone was really going to care about the
movie or its lead character. He asked Zemeckis —
"This guy sitting on a thing in these
goofy shoes and this cuckoo suit with
a suitcase full of 'Curious
George' books and stuff like
that. Are we doing anything here that
is going to make any sense to anybody?"
Hanks claims that Zemeckis did
little to reassure him. Instead,
the director supposedly responded with —
"We may be sowing the seeds
of our own destruction."
"What's my destiny, mama?"
"You're gonna have to figure
that out for yourself."
It all worked out fine — including Best Actor
and Best Director Oscar wins for the duo.
Beyond a few cameos, Rita Moreno was the only
member of the original "West Side Story" movie
cast to play a major role in the 2021 Steven
Spielberg-directed remake. In the 1961 version,
she was Anita, while in the 2021 film,
she played an entirely new character
named Valentina. Her connection to both films
makes her an important part of the overall
"West Side Story" legacy — which makes it all
the more surprising that she didn't think the
original movie, directed by Robert Wise and
Jerome Robbins, was going to be a success.
In a 2021 appearance on "60
Minutes," Moreno admitted flat out —
"I didn't even think the movie
was going [to] do that well."
She went on to explain that she pulled her
co-star George Chakiris aside on the set one
day and prepared him for the worst. She
said nobody was going to want to see the
movie because it lacked fancy costuming, had very
operatic singing at times, and was about gangs
that danced. Moreno made sure to point out that
she found the movie to be brilliant — it's just
that she didn't think it would connect with
moviegoing audiences. But it very much did,
and it won her an Oscar — which was her
first step toward her eventual EGOT.
Anyone who worked on the first couple of
entries of the Marvel Cinematic Universe
could be forgiven for being unsure if they were
making a hit — but when "The Avengers" broke
the billion-dollar mark in 2012, there was no
denying that the franchise was a massive success.
Hype only grew for the MCU — and when "Avengers:
Endgame" arrived in theaters seven years later,
it was less of a film release and more of
a worldwide cultural event. Considering
that it became the highest grossing film
ever at the time in just three months,
it's hard to imagine that anyone was
pessimistic about its chances for success.
And yet, Scarlet Witch actor Elizabeth Olsen
worried about that very thing regarding the
epic climax of the MCU's first three phases.
During a late night interview with Jimmy Fallon,
she admitted that it's difficult
for her to watch herself in new
Marvel films because she always
assumes that they'll do poorly.
"I saw 'Avengers: Endgame,' and I looked
around me and I said, 'Is it our first flop?'"
"'Avengers: Endgame' is one of the biggest
movies in the history of the world."
"Yeah. Yeah."
Only several movies in the MCU have disappointed
at the box office, and Elizabeth Olsen
hasn't appeared in any of them. It seems that
audiences always turn out for the Scarlet Witch.
With near-universal acclaim and hundreds of
millions of dollars made at the box office,
"It" ranks among the most critically and
commercially successful horror movies
ever made. That came as a huge relief to
actor Bill Skarsgård, who was convinced
something would go wrong during production.
He admitted in an interview with Variety —
"I just felt like something
really terrible was going to
happen to me personally — things
just seemed to be going too well."
Even when the film was projected to wildly
surpass the studio's most conservative estimates
of success based on early reviews, Skarsgård still
apparently managed to convince himself something
would come along and undo it all. Nothing
particularly awful ended up happening — and
even though "It: Chapter 2" didn't quite live up
to the expectations set by the first film, the two
movies brought in over a billion dollars in total.
Now all that's left is for the world to decide
whether Skarsgård is a scary-looking hot guy, a
hot-looking scary guy, or something in between.
If you had to guess who in the cast
of "Home Alone" was skeptical of its
potential to be a hit — or even a decent
movie at all — it would be understandable
to assume that the person in question
was Joe Pesci. While there has been
some anecdotal evidence to suggest
that to be the case, it was actually
John Heard, the actor behind patriarch Peter
McCallister, who loudly expressed his doubts.
While appearing on the podcast "Here's the Thing
with Alec Baldwin," director Chris Columbus
explained that John Heard didn't seem to think
that "Home Alone" was any good during production,
and he made sure that everyone around him knew it.
Once the final cut of the film premiered, though,
Heard had the same reaction as the majority of
viewers and greatly enjoyed watching his onscreen
son defend his home from the Wet Bandits.
Columbus claimed that during the production
of "Home Alone 2: Lost in New York," Heard broke
character in the middle of a scene to declare —
"I just would like to say to Chris and the crew,
I owe you a big apology. We made a great movie
the first time and I'm here to support you."
Edie Falco didn't exactly think that "Avatar:
The Way of Water" was going to fail — she
thought that it had already failed. As one of
the most ambitious sci-fi films of all time,
James Cameron's 2022 sequel needed a
whole lot of post-production to properly
transport viewers to Pandora. Editing
and effects took years to complete,
so actors had to be captured on camera quite
a while before the movie was released. It took
long enough that Falco assumed "The Way of
Water" — in which she plays General Frances
Ardmore — had already come out, flopped
at the box office, and been forgotten.
During a 2023 appearance on "The View,"
Falco explained that she filmed her scenes
for "Avatar 2" four years earlier and moved
on to other projects. Since she hadn't heard
anything about it for a while, she assumed that
it had simply come and gone without much fanfare.
"Somebody mentioned 'Avatar' and I
thought, 'Oh I guess it came out,
didn't do very well,' cause I didn't hear
anything so— but it happens, you know."
It was only when excitement ramped up for
"The Way of Water" that Falco realized it
hadn't hit theaters yet — but she was happy to
learn that it hadn't been a failure after all.
Nobody could have predicted back in 1939 that
"Gone with the Wind" was going to be discussed
and held aloft as an all-time classic
film nearly a century later. Of course,
the people making it must have at least known
they were making a good movie, right? Well,
certainly some of the cast and crew did —
but that list doesn't include Vivien Leigh,
who played Scarlett O'Hara in
the historical romance epic.
In letters discovered by The Hollywood Reporter
between Leigh and her second husband Laurence
Olivier, neither actor had high hopes for "Gone
with the Wind" — and Olivier even worried about
the damage it was going to do to Leigh's
still-rising career. Olivier wrote to Leigh —
"You have got to justify yourself
in the next two or three films (or
even two or three years) by proving that the
presumable failure of ['Gone with the Wind']
was not your fault and you can only do that
by being really good in the following parts."
Before a single review was released in the papers,
the couple were already planning Leigh's career
comeback after how badly "Gone with the Wind"
was apparently going to humiliate her. Instead,
she ended up winning her first of
two Oscars for her work in the film,
which is the highest-grossing movie of all time by
a fairly wide margin if you adjust for inflation.